[Musik]
weißt du noch was du zum 18 Geburtstag
geschenkt bekommen hast Geld von den
Eltern ein bisschen Cash von Oma und Opa
was aber wenn es noch mehr gewesen wäre
viel
mehr sagen wir 20 000 € vom ST ja vom
Start und zwar geschenkt und nicht nur
du hättest 20.000 € bekommen sondern
alle 18-Jährigen in Deutschland nein
kein Witz über Vorschläge wie diesen
wird in Deutschland tatsächlich
diskutiert bevor sich jetzt einige
vielleicht schon aufregen kurz mal Luft
holen es gibt einen Grund warum Ideen
wie ein staatliches Erbe überhaupt
diskutiert werden und der ist auch als
Protest auf unseren Straßen seit Jahren
nicht mehr zu übersehen die haben immer
mehr und die unteren haben immer weniger
und das finde ich einfach unfair
Deutschland ist ein sehr reiches
aber die Vermögen sind sehr ungleich
verteilt Immobilien
Unternehmensbeteiligungen Geldvermögen
die reichsten 10% besitzen bis zu zwei
Drittel des gesamten Vermögens in
Deutschland die reisten 1% und 1 Drittel
bei immer mehr Menschen wächst ein
irgendwie sagen wir mal uncooles Gefühl
es ist ein Gefühl von
Ungerechtigkeit und das könnte in
unserer Demokratie eine
echte Kraft
entwickeln ich bin auch hier um der
Forderung nach zu verleihen dass von
denen die sehr viel haben bisschen mehr
abgezagt wir für die Allgemeinheit denen
die mehr haben etwas wegnehmen und den
anderen geben hier kommt die Idee eines
staatlichen erbis ins Spiel könnte das
funktionieren wer hat was davon und wer
soll das bezahlen dieser Film versucht
Antworten zu finden danke schön mit
denjenigen dieon € profitieren könnten
soll
aufmachen
cool ja mit denjenigen die Unternehmen
und reiche Menschen vertreten Spoiler
sie sollen zahlen und wir sprechen mit
Wissenschaftlern die sich seit Jahren
mit der Verteilung von Vermögen in
Deutschland beschäftigen die Idee mit
den 20 000 € die hatte er mein Name ist
steefanach ich bin Steuerexperte beim
DIW deuts Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung
Berlin bevor wir gleich ins Detail gehen
was hätten sie denn mit dem Geld zum 18
gemacht oh ja viel Geld als junger
Mensch mit 18 ich denke so ein grunderbe
20.000 € ist ja unser Vorschlag hätte
mir da schon geholfen das Studium zu
finanzieren auch einfach nur so als eine
gewisse
Absicherung okay und was bedeutet
grunderbe jetzt
genau grunderbe bedeutet dass jeder
Mensch etwas erben soll also auch die
die bisher nichts erben das idealerweise
macht man das dann in jungen Jahren
damit junge Menschen ein statkapital ins
Leben bekommen denn jetzt Erben viele
nichts oder nur sehr wenig und meistens
auch erst in älteren
Jahren der Vorschlag von Stefan Bach
klingt erstmal ein
ein staatliches Erbe also ein grunderbe
von 20.000 € für alle 18-Jährigen egal
ob arm oder reich finanziert würde es
vor allem mit mehr Steuern für sehr sehr
reiche Menschen so eine Kernfrage ist ob
man ein grunderbe wirklich zur freien
Verfügung stellt oder ob man das an
bestimmte Bedingungen knüpft dass es für
Ausbildung Wohneigentum
Unternehmensgründung nur eingesetzt
werden kann dabei ist natürlich
natürlich der Nachteil das hat dann so
ein Gewissen Paternalismus dass man den
Leuten nicht zutraut dass sie das Geld
vernünftig verwenden vernünftig
verwenden man kann sich denken dass
gerade diese Frage vor allem im Netz
ziemlich heiß diskutiert wurde grunderbe
für 18-Jährige lernt erstmal wirklich
arbeiten wer arm ist hat nicht kein Geld
er ist meist schlecht im Umgang damit
ein Grundstock als stthilfe könnte
helfen ob der 18 Geburtstag der richtige
Zeit ist müsste man sehen einfach mal
ausprobieren und nicht immer alles bis
auf das kleinste Detail Tod debattieren
die glauben doch nicht ernsthaft dass
die Jugendlichen das Geld für den
Einstieg ins Arbeitsleben nutzen das
wird verfeiert oder in Klamotten Handys
und Tattoos
investiert ist das so fragen wir doch
mal nach wir haben uns mit Leuten im
Alter von 17 bis 20 Jahren verabret
verschiedene soziale backgrounds einige
kommen aus der Großstadt andere leben in
einem
Dorf ich glaube ich willürde das Geld
erstmal auf die Bank bringen und zur
Seite legen also ich würde als erstes
quasi dafür sorgen dass ich den
Führerschein undten relativ preiswertes
Auto finde für eine Wohnung sparen ich
wird es halt in musiktechnik stecken
weil ich ma selber Musik und ich glaube
da wäre sowas sinnvoll ein Grundstück
ich würde das Sparen und dann
anschließend für ein grünstück ausgeben
also ich würd ein groß teil anlegen in
ETFs bzw Aktien also dass ich noch so um
die 5000 € am Ende hab und dann halt
damit Reisen gehen nach dem Abitur also
erstes Fazit wenn man das grunderbe
bedingungslos machen würde dann wäre es
schon ziemlich wahrscheinlich dass es
für ganz unterschiedliche Dinge
ausgegeben wird ja und das ist auch
einer der Knackpunkte beim grunderbe
sagen Kritiker das grunderbe ist eine
interessante Idee Beil der sehr auf die
Details ankommt
das ist Andreas Teichel vom ifo Institut
in München auch ein Wirtschaftsforscher
wie Stefan Bach wenn das Ziel ist die
vermögensungleichheit zu reduzieren dann
muss das grunderbe zwingend zum Aufbau
von Vermögen genutzt werden das heißt es
muss in irgendeiner Form angelegt
investiert werden in Aktien in
Wertpapiere in Immobilien in eine Firma
wenn man stattdessen einen schönen
Urlaub macht oder ein neues Auto kauft
wobei Auto auch noch vielleicht ein
Vermögenswert hat für eine gewisse Zeit
dann führt es eben nicht zur Reduktion
der
vermögensungleicheit okay halten wir
fest nur wenn das Geld aus dem grunderbe
irgendwie angelegt oder investiert würde
könnte es dabei helfen ein bisschen
Vermögen aufzubauen aber wer gründet
bitteschön mit 18 ein Unternehmen
Überraschung gar nicht mal so wenige 15%
der Gründerinnen und Gründer sind
zwischen 18 und 20 Jahre alt einer von
ihnen ist
Christian cool fragen wir mal nach ich
in die Firma stecken ich will eine GmbH
gründen und da braucht man Stammkapital
von 25000 € und das ist als Schüler
bisschen schwierig ja und das wäre was
was ich wahrscheinlich damit machen
würde ja Christian ist gerade dabei
seine Geschäftsidee zu vermarkten heute
gibt er einen Workshop für Vertreterin
und Treter von Vereinen eines Dorfes in
Rheinlandpfalz
hallo
hallo Christian hat die App mein dorfnet
entwickelt seine Geschäftsidee ist eine
Plattform für Dörfer mit der
Gemeindevertretungen und Vereine
Bürgerinnen und Bürger über aktuelle
News und Events informieren können zum
Workshop sind fast alle Vereine aus
wallertime
gekommen ich würde versuchen ja
Höhepunkte des Jahres heror heben z.B
wenn es der baumschneidekurs ist der
baumschneidekurs und dann wirklich eine
Nachricht dazu und gerne auch auf das
Jahresprogramm
verlinken mit seiner App scheint
Christian einen Nerv zu treffen zwei
Gemeinden Zahlen bereits für die App
Jahresbeitrag 2800 € weitere 20 Dörfer
aus ganz Deutschland haben schon bei
Christian angefragt die Aussichten für
seinal Business scheinen also ganz gut
zu sein würdest du
die00 grunderbe wirklich komplett
investieren ich auf jeden Fall weil
20.000 € ist viel Geld aber ist auch
schnell weg und ich finde es wichtig
wenn man gerade am Anfang das Geld
kriegt das entsprechend so anzulegen
dass es im Idealfall mehr wird oder dass
man ganz viel draus lernt dass man an
persönlichen Wert steigert und das ist
glaube ich über die Firma der Weg für
mich den persönlichen Wert zu steigern
interessant
ja bei einer Firmengründung könnte das
ein Nebeneffekt des grunderbes sein auf
jeden Fall sammelt Christian gerade
schon super viel berufliche Erfahrung in
seiner dorfapp steckt echt noch eine
Menge Arbeit drin geh um 7 Uhr in die
Schule dann komme ich so gegen 3 zurück
dann fängt mein Arbeitstag an und dann
arbeite ich so in etwa bis 21 Uhr genau
meistens aber auch auf dem Klo in der
schule aber das darf keiner
wissen chran istem der sich schon früh
darum gekümmert hat eine
Gründungsförderung zu bekommen Startup
Teens zweiter Platz bei jugendgründet
wie könnte ein grunderbe jungen
Unternehmerinnen und Unternehmern helfen
Christian das grunderbe bietet die
Möglichkeit ohne sich zu überlegen
welche Regeln man erfüllen muss einfach
an finanzielle Mittel zu kommen und was
wenn das Geld an Bedingungen geknüpft
wäre Bedingung bedeutet Bürokratie
Bedingung bedeutet erstmal ganz viel
Geld ausgeben ohne dass es an kommt
nämlich Geld für Mitarbeiter die
entscheiden sind die Bedingungen erfüllt
ganz viel Ressourcen verschwenden das
sind eigentlich immer Bedingungen das
heißt eigentlich muss man eine Lösung
finden dass jeder von selber diese
Bedingung einfach erfüllen will und das
schafft man glaube ich dann für die
Masse der Gesellschaft wenn man im
Bildungssystem herangeht und
fünfkläern schon fünfkläern beibringt
Probleme kritisch zu hinterfragen also
auch Bildung spielt eine Rolle danke
Christian was denken die anderen die das
Geld bekommen würden bräuchte es Regeln
für das grunderbe also ich finde man
sollte niemanden zwingen Geld für etwas
Bestimmtes auszugeben weil das Geld
gehört ja dann der Person die Person
sollte eigentlich selber damit umgehen
können und auch selber sagen können ich
möchte es genau dafür ausgeben oder halt
eben nicht vielleicht möchte die Person
es ja auch einfach sparen so wie ich es
gern sparen möchte und dann sollte man
kein einfach zwingen einfach mal machen
lassen ist die Frage
wer das Geld dann auch wirklich dann gut
anlegen würde wer damit gut umgehen
würde aber das kann man ja nicht
voraussagen da muss man sich einfach
drauf verlassen da muss man auch drauf
vertrauen können aber ich glaube ehrlich
gesagt dass das gar nicht so viel
ausgenutzt wird wie vielleicht
befürchtet weil viele Leute das auch
wertschätzen können
also ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl wenn
ich das wenn ich das Geld einfach her so
hätte wenn ich auf der Straße finden
würde würde ich wahrscheinlich sagen ich
geb es aus tatsächlich aus für irgendwas
wie ein wie ein Auto oder
irgend irgendein Teil von irgendwas in
einer Wohnung was weiß ich aber dadurch
dass es ja vom Start kommt
hätte hätte ich irgendwie das Gefühl ich
habe jetzt eine Verantwortung etwas
Vernünftiges damit zu machen deswegen
haben Stefan Bach und seine Kollegen das
grunderbe auch mal unter bestimmten
Bedingungen durchgerechnet genau für so
eine erste Berechnung zu den Wirkungen
des grunderbes nehmen wir an dass alle
18-Jährigen über 30 Jahre 20.000 €
bekommen haben und auch nicht ausgeben
und dann stellt man schon fest dass das
schon durchaus einen spürbaren Effekt
auf die Vermögensverteilung hat
insbesondere bei den unteren
vermögensgruppen die ja nur sehr wenig
Vermögen haben kann es sich verdoppeln
bei 20.000 € Andreas peichel fragt sich
dabei allerdings noch warum wirklich
alle das grunderbe bekommen sollen warum
muss man auch einem Millionen oder
Milliarden Erben mit 18
eben auch noch etwas geben das man führt
dazu wenn man es jedem gibt das wird
insgesamt teurer es ist weniger
zielgerichtet und wenn man es
zielgenauer machen könnte nur an die
Ärmsten Hälfte der Bevölkerung z.B dann
könnten die das Doppelte bekommen warum
wird das gunderbe an jeden gezahlt nun
das ist natürlich erstmal der einfache
Weg und es wäre relativ aufwendig zu
kontrollieren welche Vermögen da bereits
vorhanden sind geschweige denn dass man
kontrolliert wie viel Vermögen die
Eltern haben
selbst wenn die Eltern viel Vermögen
haben ist ja nicht gewährleistet dass es
auch ihren Kindern geben dass da hinter
noch was übrig bleibt oder die Eltern
können es weggeben können auch pleite
gehen so dass dieses Konzept eines
bedingungslosen grunderbe so ähnlich wie
beim
grundinkommen sich hier schon anbietet
aber es bedeutet natürlich dass es
sozusagen mit der Gießkanne über die
gesamte junge Generation verteilt wird
okay dann haben wir ein zweites Fazit
wenn der Staat kontrollieren wollte an
wen das grunderbe genau ausgezahlt wird
und auch für was es genau ausgegeben
wird müsste er dafür wohl irgendwelche
Kontrollstrukturen schaffen Kontrolle
bedeutet aber meistens Bürokratie und
die kostet in der Regel Geld was
wiederum die Kosten für das grunderbe
erhöhen würde PU man merkt schon es ist
nicht so einfach und es wird noch
komplizierter
fakt ist nämlich auch die
Rahmenbedingungen sind in Deutschland
nicht für alle gleich Männer besitzen
mehr Vermögen als Frauen wer Eltern ohne
höheren Bildungsabschluss hat hat
schlechtere Karten Vermögen aufzubauen
und Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit
Migrationshintergrund liegen unter dem
Durchschnitt je nachdem wo man wohnt
gibt es ebenfalls krasse Unterschiede
die Menschen im Westen z.B besitzen
deutlich höhere Vermögen als die im
Osten zwei bis dreimal so
hoch unser vermögenspotenzial hängt also
rein statistisch gesehen auch ein
bisschen von Umständen ab die wir nicht
zu 100% selbst beeinflussen
können Frau aus dem Osten
Migrationshintergrund mal ganz plakativ
gesehen
hi das ist Kassandra wir treffen sie in
ihrer WG in Bonn wir haben dir was
mitgebracht
was hättest du
mit00€ zum 18 Geburtstag
gemacht hät mir glaube ich sehr
viel
Stress Kassandra studiert Jura und lernt
gerade für das erste stsexamen heiße
Phase die nächste Probeklausur steht an
harard an der Wand du hast große Träume
oder
das hab natürlich eine schöne
un Kassandra will und muss das Examen
unbedingt im ersten Anlauf schaffen ein
Scheitern kann sie sich nicht leisten
denn wenn eines in ihrem Leben immer
knapp war dann war es das
Geld also Geld hat in der
Hinsicht Rolle gespielt als dass ich als
Kind irgendwie schon früher erkannt habe
okay im Vergleich vielleicht zu anderen
Mitschülern und Mitschülerinnen dass wir
vielleicht
nicht super viel Geld hatten kassandra
ist als Tochter einer Philippiner und
eines US-Amerikaners in Deutschland
aufgewachsen schon in der Schule ist für
sie klar sie will Juristin werden und
dass es ohne Stipendium nicht gehen wird
ihr Traum droht aber gleich am Anfang zu
zerplatzen ich habe letztlich dann mit
dem Studium schon angefangen ohne
eigentlich sichere Studienfinanzierung
zu haben also bei dem Stipendium hat das
auswahverfahren noch ein bisschen länger
gedauert bfek hat sich auch Zeit
gelassen das heißt ich habe schon ich
war schon im zweiten Monat meines
Studiums und hatte noch keine einzige
studiensicherung das war natürlich eine
super stressige Zeit
und ja hatte so ein bisschen Angst dass
mir das Geld dann letztlich nicht mehr
weicht und ich wusste nicht wie lange
ich das durchziehen kann oder ob ich ich
vielleicht sogar schon relativ früh
abbrechen
[Musik]
muss ihr Freund ist schließlich ihre
Rettung oder besser seine Eltern sie
leihen Cassandra 1000 € um die ersten
Wochen finanziell zu überstehen hätte
ich mit 18 20 000 € bekommen wären diese
Unsicherheiten schon von Anfang an gar
nicht da gewesen das heißt Sicherheit
war für mich gerade am Anfang des
Studiums ein sehr sehr großer Faktor den
ich nicht hatte der mich häufig zweifeln
lassen hat ob das die wichtige
Entscheidung gewesen ist ob ich nicht
vielleicht doch lieber eine Ausbildung
hätte beginnen sollen wo eine
finanzielle Sicherung schon von Anfang
an da gewesen wäre letztendlich hat es
Cassandra mit einem Stipendium und einem
Studienkredit von 14 000 € jetzt
tatsächlich bis zum Examen geschafft was
hältst du denn von der Idee ein
grunderbe wirklich an alle also auch an
vermögende zu zahlen also ich finde es
halt super wichtig auch zu beachten dass
eben nicht jeder der als vermögend
abgestempelt ist oder eben vermögend ist
auch per
se das Geld hat um ein Studium zu machen
also ganz also ich kenne einige Leute
die eben die Schwelle fürs barfck nicht
mehr erreicht haben also kein barfack
bekommen und sich trotzdem das studi
komplett selber finanzieren müssen eben
dann auch sehr viel neben dem Studium
eben arbeiten um sich das finanzieren zu
können genau weil die Eltern
beispielsweise eben ihre Kinder in der
Hinsicht nicht unterstützen wollen weil
s jetzt vielleicht irgendwie in
Studiengang angestrebt haben mit denen
Sie nicht einverstanden sind weil sie
sich mit denen verstritten haben wenn
Cassandra erzählt wird deutlich dass es
um mehr geht als um Geld klar mit 20.000
€ hätte Kassandra stressfrei ins Studium
St können aber es spielt auch eine große
Rolle wie wir aufwachsen welche Chancen
wir bekommen und ob wir die dann auch
nutzen
können viel Glück für die Prüfungen
[Musik]
Kassandra so über eine Sache haben wir
noch gar nicht geredet was soll das
grunderbe eigentlich genau Kosten Herr
Bach das grunderbe würde den stat 15
Milliarden Euro im Jahr kosten das ist
noch zu finanzieren bedeutet aber
natürlich entsprechende
Steuererhöhungen
sinnvollerweise auf hohe Vermögen die
Erbschaftssteuer bietet sich da ja an
dann kriegen die einen eben das
grunderbe und das wird dann eben über
höhere erbschaffssteuern finanziert die
sehr wohlhabenden belasten sagen wir mal
die Top 1%. ist natürlich eine
Herausforderung dann wirklich nur die
großen Vermögen zu
belasten weil die ja auch häufig
unternehmerisch gebunden sind
tatsächlich ist das Vermögen vieler
wohlhabender Menschen in Deutschland in
irgendeiner Form mit einem Unternehmen
verbunden BMW Volkswagen Bertelsmann der
Springerverlag Miele Henkel um nur
einige wenige der bekannten zu nennen
fast 90% aller deutschen Unternehmen
werden von Familien kontrolliert sie
beschäftigen viele Millionen Menschen
lange Rede kurzer Sinn das hier ist al
te wirtschaftliche Macht an der viele
Arbeitsplätze hängen und deshalb gibt es
bei der Erbschaftssteuer auch Ausnahmen
für
Firmenerben wir haben das Problem dass
wir relativ hohe Steuersätze haben die
gehen bis zu 50% bei der
Erbschaftssteuer und dafür aber relativ
große Ausnahmen vereinfacht ist es so
wenn man ein ein eine Firma vererbt oder
schenkt an die nächste ation und unter
der Bedingung dass diese Firma
weitergeführt wird dann ist diese
Übertragung mehr oder weniger komplett
von der Steuer freigestellt bzw auf
Antrag kann das dann gestundet werden
ach so und was würden Unternehmen dazu
sagen wenn man die Ausnahmen beim
Vererben von Firmenanteilen einfach
abschafft fragen wir doch mal jemanden
der die Interessen von
Familienunternehmen vertritt und mit
deren Steuersituation vertraut
ich heiße Roland Franke und bei der
Stiftung Familienunternehmen und
Politik bin ich der Leiter Steuer und
Finanzpolitik es gibt ja im politischen
Spektrum die Forderung die Regeln zum
Schutz des Betriebsvermögens ersatzlos
zu streichen das würde bedeuten wenn ein
Unternehmen oder
Unternehmensanteile im Familienkreis
vererbt werden das dann ungefeht
eine Steuerlast von bis zu 30% entstehen
würde wenn der
Unternehmensanteil 100 Millionen Euro
wert ist dann würde das heißen es müssen
etwa 30 Millionen Euro Steuern gezahlt
werden auch
Unternehmenserben die solche Anteile
Erben haben nicht 30 Millionen Euro
unterm Kopfkissen sondern das Geld
muss im Grunde dann aus dem Unternehmen
entnommen werden das würde heißen je
nachdem wie schnell die Steuerschuld
beglichen werden muss dass Teile des
Unternehmens verkauft werden müssten
okay fassen wir noch mal
zusammen für das grunderbe müsste der
Staat 15 Milliarden Euro
zusammenbekommen z.B über mehr
Erbschaftssteuern von sehr reichen
Menschen deren Vermögen sind aber häufig
in Unternehmen gebunden und für das
Vererben von Unternehmen oder Anteilen
daran gibt es steuerliche Ausnahmen die
dazu führen dass der Staat an dieser
Stelle kaum Erbschaftssteuern einnimmt
im Klartext die 15 Milliarden ließen
sich über Erbschaftssteuern nur dann
finanzieren wenn der Staat die
Steuerausnahmen für Unternehmenserben
abschafft dafür müsste die
Erbschaftssteuer aber reformiert werden
und genau das Schlagen nicht nur
Experten wie Bach oder vor sondern eine
Reform wird auch in verschiedenen
Parteien diskutiert ziehen wir an dieser
Stelle einfach ein letztes fazit Die
grunderbeidee hört sich zwar erstmal
einfach an aber in der Realität hätte
sie mit sehr vielen sehr komplexen
Herausforderungen zu kämpfen und jetzt
war das nicht ganz es gibt tatsächlich
Menschen die nicht nur reden sondern
einfach mal machen chr ist einer alle
wir losfahren du weißt wohin zusammen
mit seinem Sohn tourt er im Spätsommer
durch Deutschland und verlost ein
grunderbe im Wert von 20 000 € insgesamt
dreimal pro Jahr warum weil ich bin ich
bin überzeugt dass das der Weg ist wie
unser Zusammenleben in diesem Land eine
neue Qualität erreichen kann vor 13
Jahren hat Christoph Prümm die Stiftung
ein Erbe für jeden gegründet zusammen
mit anderen Aktivistinnen und Aktivisten
noch schnell ein Kaffee bevor sie gleich
die letzten 20 000 € für dieses Jahr
auswürfeln wollen die Idee von einer Art
grunderbe fasziniert Christoph brümm
schon sein ganzes Leben lang er ist in
einem kleinen Dorf an der Mosel
aufgewachsen wir saßen glaube ich damals
alle noch zusammen in einer Schulklasse
und es war eigentlich erkennbar schon
was aus jedem
wird von seiner Herkunft her nicht
unbedingt von seiner Begabung von seinen
Interessen her sondern von seiner
Herkunft her bestimmt zu sein und der
Gedanke dass es einen Ausgleich geben
könnte oder müsste der kann wir damals
schon und den habe ich auch damals schon
diskutiert das Geld für ihre
grunderbestiftung müssen sie jedes Jahr
neu auftreiben die Spender wollen anonym
bleiben dann ziehen die beiden los in
einem Kulturzentrum in Gütersloh haben
sie einen Raum gemietet also mir wissen
nicht wer kommt sieht ja niedlich aus
hier in den letzten Tagen haben sie hier
in der Region dazu gerufen sich für die
grunderbeverlosung anzumelden einzige
Bedingung hier nicht 18 sondern 30 muss
man sein und bereit die 20000 € 3 Jahre
lang anzulegen danach darf man das Geld
ausgeben egal wofür in Gütersloh haben
sich mehr als 400 Leute angemeldet
gekommen ist aber nur ein
Bruchteil keine Frage chr hat eine
Mission und bevor hier gleich ausgelost
wird nutzt er die Gelen seine Idee von
einer chancengerechten Gesellschaft zu
erklären mich stört nicht dass nicht mal
das einige mehr kriegen als einige wen
weniger kriegen mich stört vor allem
dass sehr viele die Hälfte gar nichts
kriegen genau und gar nichts Null und
ich sehe unser Land so ein bisschen auch
wie eine Familie und in jener
anständigen Familie GI gibt es ein
Pflichtteilsrecht das heißt dass keiner
übersehen werden darf dass keiner
komplett übersehen werden darf ist
Christoph Prümm einfach bloß ein
Idealist ein Träumer der eine Idee
verfolgt die in unserer Gesellschaft
sowieso nie Realität werden wird oder
könnte das grunderbe vielleicht doch
irgendwann mal von der Politik umgesetzt
werden Herr Bach tatsächlich stellt man
eben fest dass es da auch eine gewisse
Offenheit gibt auch in den großen
Volksparteien so in der SPD wurde das
Thema bereits aufgegriffen die CDU
diskutiert das in ihrem neuen
Grundsatzprogramm also es kann durchaus
sein dass zumindest gewisse Elemente
davon aufgegriffen werden in den
nächsten Jahren inzwischen haben
Christoph Prümm und sein Sohn jemanden
aus dem Publikum gebeten die Nummer für
das gewinnerlos auszuwürfeln nur ein ne
oder ein N kann heute nach dem
Zufallsprinzip Geld bekommen die anderen
werden leer ausgehen warum sollte unsere
Gesellschaft dieses Prinzip durchbrechen
Herr peichel wenn die Schere zwischen
Arm und Reich immer weiter auseinander
geht wird es zu einer weiteren
Polarisierung der Gesellschaft kommen
und das nicht nur beim Geld und Vermögen
sondern auch im politischen Bereich und
das ist natürlich dann insgesamt auch
potenziell schlecht für den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland weil äh
wir sind aufgrund der demografischen
Entwicklung z.B auf Zuwanderung
angewiesen und wenn wir natürlich eine
ein sehr polarisiertes radikalisiertes
Umfeld haben dann wer will dann noch
nach Deutschland kommen wer will dann
hier arbeiten wer will hier investieren
aus dem Ausland und und insofern besteht
da schon die Gefahr dass wenn
Deutschland immer ungleicher wird dass
wir auch wirtschaftlich abgehängt werden
irgendwann und das wäre dann wirklich
schlecht für unser gesamtes Land
übrigens der Gewinner des grunderbes
erfährt am Telefon von seinem Glück sie
sind die erste gewürfelte
Losnummer und dann machen sich Christoph
und Sebastian Prüm wieder auf den Weg
das Geld für die grunderbeverlosungen im
nächsten Jahr
[Musik]
aufzutreiben